Welcome to the lecture on database implementation. In the last lecture we have looked at different ways to compose operators.
Actually how to implement the operator interface so that we can compose them.
We first looked at full materialization where we said okay, that's of course the simplest model.
We read all the input and then we write back all the results into a new relation. Very easy.
There's not so great performance. Iterator model where we produce each tuple on demand.
So then we had looked at the block pass model, where we pass not a single tuple, but blocks
of tuple, so this amortizes the call overhead, which is much more efficient than the iterator
model.
But there is a problem that we write quite a few data, and then the push model, so where
the data is not pulled up, so it is set from the leaves of the exclusion plan, pushed up
We also started looking at example code for this.
So, functionalization iterator, this is what we did.
And then blockwise processing, this is what we also did.
And we stopped about here.
So we stopped here, so in the push model, then okay, how can we look and implement the
three most primitive operators, scan, select and cross product using the push model.
So the code is actually quite simple, as you see here.
So in this scan code we say okay we want to scan the relation R and then we call open
we just remember what is the relation R that I want to scan and also I remember who wants
to read it, so consumer here, this is an object or some kind of callback, and then we want
to produce data then we can literally do it.
So we loop over all the tuples in R and then we just pass each tuple to R.
Here is a tuple, here is a tuple, here is a tuple.
So it is very simple.
Now note that in the produce-consume world scan of course has no consume because scan
is a leaf.
So scan can only produce, we never have an input.
Now when we come to select, select does have an input and produces output values.
So when we call produce on the select, we just call produce on the input here.
We just say please give me all the tuples.
Now in the consume callback, so when we get a tuple, we check the condition if it's true,
we pass it along to our consumer here, if not we throw it away.
Okay?
And cross product, so when we want to build a cross between the two inputs,
so in the open call we just remember what's left to right was my consumer.
Now when we call cross produce, this means we ask our left side please produce tuples.
a tuple from the left, note that in reality, I mean I didn't show this in full interface,
but it's a consume interface, you might also know from where the tuple comes. So here we say
the tuple comes from my left input, then we store the tuple here and then we call it produce on my
right side. Okay and when we get the tuple from my right, then we combine it with my store tuple
here and then we output to our consumer.
So actually this code here is very, very simple.
Of course for more complex operators it is not that simple, but nevertheless it does
not have the complexity of the iterator model that has to remember where you are, such that
you can stop at any point in time.
And now so far we have only looked at open and whatever we need to produce tablets next
or so. Of course there are also other functions that we have to implement. One is close, this is
usually a pretty boring function, we just release allocated resources like the free memory, we close
the file, whatever our operator did, so this is pretty simple. Then there are some other
functionalities that we might need that are a bit more advanced, like the first one here is
rewind rebind. Now what is this? These are two functions that look very similar but behave
Rebind means if somebody calls rebind, this says please prepare for re-execution.
So I want to read you again, please prepare for re-execution.
But you can reuse what you have already have.
So this is basically what rebind is.
Rebind means I want to prepare for re-execution, but you must recompute what you already have.
Now why do we need this to function?
ideas now so the easiest case is we have just something like this and so we have uh here
there's a loop join so then r and s so then we need rewind because we take a tupper from r we
read s and now when the next tupper from r comes we tell s please i want to read you again note of
course this is the base table of course is a pretty boring but this could be something complex
large plan and if the next table comes we want to read it again if we do not read necessarily
have to recompute it now because if for example if the top ones operate is a group i also
we can just reuse what you already have in my group by table so we don't have to
recompute it we just read it again while the rebind case we need for another operator namely
for the dependent join so where when for example maybe we have something like this here
so if you have something like this note that the right hand side of the join depends on the left
hand side here because we're on the right hand side we use a to put some R of course this happens
but this can happen.
And if this happens now,
we must, if now we get a new topper from R,
we must throw away the group by results.
We cannot reuse it.
Therefore we must call rebind.
So then now in the real implementation,
we might even track which attribute to change
because sometimes we can reuse some part of the plan,
some others we don't,
but nevertheless with this functionality we also need.
We often also need functionality for memory management
because operators tend to allocate memory.
We want to freeze them probably,
memory pressure, so there might be operators for that.
And you might need more functions for spooling.
So if you run out of memory,
we want to have a functionality to write my result to disk,
my image result to disk, and then read it back.
And so we skip all this.
Another interesting problem here is
what do we actually do with the subscripts?
And so I, you saw already in the example here,
so that when we say, I say A equals B,
so this is of course the subscript here.
but I mean a equals b is always very simple but there can be anything in there yeah so we can for
example write two times a plus b should be less than c or whatever yeah so this can be an arbitrarily
complex over expression and of course we need some mechanism to evaluate this expression
now it's these subscripts here they are the query specific part of the query so for the other
operators we have seen join select we didn't look at join but select cross product and so on
the implementations we have seen don't really care about the query they only talk about control flow
everything that is query specific is handled by subscript as this can be something simple like
just access an attribute so somebody says x or a give me an attribute value or we can have a
predicate of a equals p or we can have some computation or really can be anything you know
and of course now we must somehow implement this such that when a user gives me a query
I'm able to evaluate whatever expression is included in the query and first of course
the squares always look different so the subscripts always look different but on the plus side
these are usually pretty simple a equals b is a very simple expression now you can write something
complex but this happens much more rarely and even if you write a complex expression the operation
itself is easy, a comparison, a plus, a minus, multiplication.
These are all very simple operations,
nothing compared to a join or so.
So that means we have to implement all these functions
somehow is a large number, but conceptually simple.
Also here we have different ways
like implement this.
So the first choice is something,
for example, that DB2 does,
or at least did, I'm not sure if they still do this,
but they did at some point.
they use interpreter objects.
So which basically means you built a small tree, like a tree looks like this here, you
say, my example here doesn't do plus, but could also be plus or let's say equality gets
two inputs here and my input here in this case could be for example, access int, access,
So this is how we can check the condition A equals B.
So we say we express this as a tree, comparison is the top most element and then we have access
to the output further down.
And of course if you do something more complex, like if you do A plus B equals C, so this
works just the same, we have equality at the top, then here we have a plus, then here we
have A, B and then here we have C.
So this, we can accept whatever expression we have, we can build such a tree of objects.
And if we want to evaluate this, we just take the root of this tree and we call evaluate
on this, on this root.
So here now you see some example code.
So when we want to access an attribute, this is what we see here.
Note we want to, here this is called access int, which means we want to access an attribute
that is an integer value.
so then we it gets a pointer here and then we is a tuple pointer and then we say okay please take
a tuple look at the corresponding offset load the value and then return it so this is accessing an
attribute and if you want to do a comparison so this is an integer comparison so then we say okay
i take my left side i call a validator on my left side here i take my right side i will call a valid
on my right side and then i just compare here the two values okay so and yeah you can implement this
for whatever you want plus minus all works the same so you just implement an eval function and
then you can assemble them as you want so this is a good thing about this approach is very easy to
implement now you basically need one line per operator or two lines per operator is a very very
lightweight very flexible also quite popular quite a few people use such in the model
you have is not very fast.
Now the problem is whenever you even think about
this trivial example like A equals B,
when then we had an equality as root,
then we had an excess for A and excess for B.
This extremely simple expression already involves
three virtual function calls.
And because we first call the root,
this calls the left side, this calls the right side,
and then we submit the result.
So virtual function calls are a bit more expensive.
So this is not super fast.
easy, flexible, but not very fast. Now what else can we do? We can decide that
instead of using interpreter objects we compile my expressions into a
small virtual machine. I'm not sure if you are familiar with how virtual machines
work like JVM for example or other engines basically you
construct a sequence of like pseudo opcodes that you can execute and each
And then when you want to execute this you loop over this list of opcodes and you evaluate
whatever it is.
So this is the equivalent what we saw before.
So you see here on the first line we look at the current instruction and then I say
okay look at the next instruction, take its command and then we do switch over whatever
the command is.
Then if the command here is access integer then we do it.
here you see already here we load the value just as that before we forward with the result
we now store it here in some register files. We have a register file and the output register
stored in my opcode. Some opcode says where should the result be stored and when the comparison
function comes here so this is the next comparison then we say we get two arguments from opcode,
take the register value from first argument, take the register value from the second argument,
and compare them and write the result here to this one.
Okay, and this you can also get implemented with the operations that you have.
This is more efficient than an interpreter object.
Because you just have one big loop, it's a one big switch and you can, if you are particularly
use tricks like computer go-tos in your compiler, you can make the switch here very fast.
So this is more efficient than calling.
Downside of course is also more complex to generate this.
Basically you need a compiler that takes your SQL expression
and compiles it into some form of bytecode.
It's not very difficult to build such a compiler,
but you must do this.
So you must now say,
okay, I translate my expression into the sequence.
So I said I had a equals b,
and now translate it into a sequence of operations like
XsInt, XsInt, and then compare echoInt.
So you get through three instructions.
Okay, this is also a decent choice and quite a few systems do this.
So this is also a very valid option.
Now, another technique that is popular in systems like VectorVise, for example, is this one here.
Okay, yeah, of course, and we have a very different queries, but in reality, the number
of primitives that we have, like plus, minus, plus, equality, and so on, this is not that
high.
Yeah, so we can just have them prepared somewhere.
And what we can also do, we can hide the overhead of calling them.
Like the interpreter object, of course, does the same.
We also have prepared code for all parameters that we have in our system, but we want to
hide the high coiling overhead of the interpreter, but not coiling it for one value, but coiling
it for many values.
And therefore it's called to code vectorized execution.
So we do process vector at a time.
So here now you see a comparison function that takes as input two vectors.
So this is one vector of values.
This is the second vector of values, so two integer vectors and we output a result vector
which contains Boolean's and of course we must tell it how many elements it has.
And now what this function does here, it loops over all values in the both two vectors, compares
them here and writes the results to the original output.
So you perform a primitive operation for a large number of input values.
this can be quite efficient in particular if you start using SIMD instructions also for comparison
so these pre-compiled fragments can be quite efficient but of course this requires that the
input is available as nice vectors that you can access and so this more or less means you can
only use this if your input is a column store and probably only for overlap systems so there are quite
a few constraints that you have but if you fall into this constraint this is a very very viable
strategy performance of these engines is good okay so you can average subscript like this
or the fourth option is we take my subscript and we generate machine comfort yeah and so
this is not sure if you're familiar with reading assembler code but basically what we're doing here
is we are loading values so we here we are loading a pointer into my AX register loading
a value relative to that pointer yeah so this is so this will be a my code here this will
be a column a column pointer and we're loading a column point at a certain tupl id here so
we're loading value into my register and look at the second column and load the second value
and then I do a comparison.
Okay.
So this is again, we access two integer values
and we compare.
This of course is about the most efficient agenda of this.
I mean, do you generate here five assembler codes,
five assembler instructions
and basically you cannot do better.
In SIMD can help sometimes,
but in general, this is about the most efficient you can do.
Only downside is, of course,
is also the most difficult.
So generating machine code is more involved than,
of course, the interpreter objects,
but also more involved than generating VM code.
Another problem here is portability.
So what do you do if you don't want to run on Intel,
but want to run on ARM?
So this is of course also a challenge.
We will look at this later in the lecture
in the section code generation.
Okay, and another interesting thing to keep in mind
when talking about operator implementations is pipelining.
So now what do we mean with pipelining?
Usually we try to avoid copying data around
because each copy costs me something.
It costs me space, but also cost me performance
because I have to run a lot of instructions.
And if you manage to pass data between operators
without making your copies, this we call pipelining.
So basically implicitly passing data
from one operator to another.
Now, sometimes this is not possible.
yeah so sometimes operator materializes input and then we call this operator a pipeline breaker
so this operator we cannot pass around and in even more extreme case of this is if an operator
consumes its input completely before producing any output then we call this a full pipeline breaker
so this is the most extreme variant of a pipeline breaker a full pipeline breaker materialize
everything and then start producing.
And so there are operators that binary operators in particular that break only one side.
So it's not only you are a pipeline breaker, but also where are you breaking the pipeline.
So let's make an example.
So this one here, a selection, this is not a pipeline breaker.
Why?
Because we can take a tuple, of course you have some condition here, but we can take
a tuple, check the condition and just pass the data along to the next one.
So the selection is usually not a pipeline breaker.
So the other extreme end of the spectrum is this one here, SORT.
SORT clearly is a pipeline breaker and in fact it is a full pipeline breaker.
Why is it a full pipeline breaker?
Because the last input tuple to SORT might be the first output tuple.
Therefore we cannot output anything before we have seen all the input.
And therefore SORT breaks the pipeline fully.
materialize all my inputs. So this is the other extreme and then there are other
forms like for example this one here. This is also a pipeline breaker but it's
not a full pipeline breaker. Why? Because we can output tuples even though at
least on one side and even though we have not seen my input completely. For
example if you have a five-year tuple that does have a joint partner it can immediately output
this value. Doesn't matter what comes later. So this is not a full, it's a
pipeline breaker and finally this one here so when we talk about hash join
this will break the pipeline on the left usually on the build side we draw it
usually as the left this is built and probe so we do break the pipeline on the
build side because we put the build side in a hash table but we do not break the
pipeline on the probe side because for a prop tuple we look at the hash table
we will check for matches and then output the value.
Okay, so this is just to illustrate
what is a pipeline breaker and where we do this.
And of course, if you break the pipeline or not,
this has implications for other operators,
like can we still access values?
And so like if somebody breaks the pipeline,
this usually means that pointers become invalid.
And so if the pipeline is broken,
I can no longer reference a tuple by a pointer
after the operator,
measure but if my pipeline is preserved the parallel is not broken i can still continue
using pointers and other effects okay yeah so this is just what i said so we affect the behavior
so if a pipeline break is between a source and a sink the original data is no longer accessible
so pointers are becoming invalid and this is relevant if we do tricks like lazy attribute
access so which means we load an attribute only in the moment that we need it if somebody is about
pipeline and must load it at this point in time because otherwise my input is gone.
Or think what do we do with strings, do we have to make a copy of the strings or this
kind of strings or do we do tabular djoins and we only join a tabular d and load the
rest later so there are all kinds of games and we must know this.
And on the other hand if there is a full pipeline breaker between the holes and the sink then
we know that my execution plan is broken into fragments so everything before the full pipeline
breaker and everything after and if this occurs multiple times i can for example execute these
parts in parallel so the full pipeline breaker really means these two are decoupled so i can
run them in parallel or i can schedule them or all kinds of things okay and therefore to make this
correct the code generation must know if an operator is a pipeline breaker and where the
And we, in fact, we will make it so that we will make
this pipeline explicitly.
So we say the pipeline goes from A to B,
and then we know precisely how the data flow works.
Okay, and now another interesting question is,
what do we do with parallelization?
So on today's machines,
you have quite a significant number of cores.
So like the desktop machine I'm currently sitting on
has 16 cores, 32 with hyper,
And this is not so super powerful machine.
I mean, it's quite a good one,
but you can definitely buy much larger machines.
And so you can easily have a computer
with 64 cores or even more.
And so if you have such a high number of cores,
then of course it doesn't make sense
to execute everything single threaded,
because otherwise you're wasting most of your system.
And now how should we do this?
Now, the easy problem of course is interqueryl parallelism,
which just means we take two queries and run them parallel.
This is super easy and we don't have to do anything special.
Now, if you want to parallelize within a query,
so if you want to do intra-query parallelism,
then this is much more difficult.
But of course, in practice, we need intra-query parallelism
because it could be that the user comes to us
with a very big query, a very complicated query,
and we have only one query in my system,
so I must do my best to execute this as fast as we can.
Therefore, we need intra-query parallelism.
Now also here there are easy and not so easy problems.
So easy part is if we have independent parts of the query, for example, because of full
pipeline breakers, so I know that these parts are independent, then I can just run them
in parallel without doing anything.
This is also easy.
Now if you want to parallelize in a single operator, then this is more difficult.
and for example it takes this one,
where if we have a big table here,
say a big table,
and then on top of this big table is a group i.
So there's only two operators,
a table scan and a group i,
and here I compute some group i,
and I compute some or something like this.
So how do I do this in parallel?
Usually the strategy is we look at the input
of the group i, of this big table,
and we partition it.
into let's say 16 pieces, if we have 16 cores,
and then each core aggregates 1 16th of the data,
and then we aggregate the results,
then we produce a real output.
Now for this simple query,
this still works quite easily.
In general, this is more difficult
to how to make everything parallel.
And therefore we will cover this later in the lecture,
but I'd already want to mention this,
this is a problem that we have to look at.
Okay, so now after giving a very brief overview over the high level aspects of set oriented
processing, I now want to look at the individual algebraic operators and discuss how to implement
these.
Also because so far we have only looked at table scan, select and cross product and these
are of course all trivial operators, they don't do anything.
These are very easy, so now we must look at more complex ones.
Okay, and so when we run queries, all queries, at least in most systems, all queries are
translated into relational algebra.
So everything that we do, we express using relational algebra.
And so if we want to offer certain implementation, we must express this in these algebraic operators.
And often, not always, but often we have more than one implementation.
So why do we need more than one implementation?
For example, if I want to run a group by, if for example I would know that my input is
sorted on A and I grouped by A, then the group by is trivial.
I don't have to do anything because I know everything that belongs to the same group
will be next to each other in the input.
So it is very, very simple.
While if my input is not sorted on A, then I must do something, so therefore I probably
as if if we want to cover the special case same with with joints you most likely have at least
two joint implementations potentially more but two is about the minimum that you that you need
yeah and so you will have and probably as for other operators you will have different
implementations sitting around now we will start with simple operators and then look at more
complex one i just want to say the complexity between operators varies
So there are a few operators that are very simple, select for example, super simple.
So a few simple operators, but most operators tend to be quite complex.
So join is a complex operator, group wise even worse.
So these are quite complicated operators.
And so as a rough rule of thumb, we can say pipeline operators tend to be simple because
they pass data around and pipeline breakers tend to be complex.
It's not always true, this is a rule of thumb,
but most cases it's true.
So this gives you an already quite an idea what to expect.
Okay, and we now look at the operators in sequence.
Again, we start with a very simple one, table scan.
We just produce all tuples content in the relations.
Conceptually this is super simple.
And now the real implementation could be more involved.
Yeah, so it depends on what the table scan does.
Now first the table scan of course has to navigate the physical representation
so which means we have to find the place where my data is stored which is not
necessarily super complicated but depending how your storage layer works
can be not non-trivial so here on the bottom you see example implementation
of a reasonable simple table scan so but as you say so what we do here in the
first loop we look at all page extents so we look at the sequence of pages that we have
that belongs to the relations we look at the page extent e here then we loop over all pages
in the page extent here then here we say we fix a page now finally that we have a page
with tuples we loop over all tuples in the page and pass it to my consumer and of course
implicitly here not mentioned there must be some kind of load logic or at least a lazy
load so there must be some way to load the attribute value and so we take my tuple and
pass it to my consumer and then when i'm done with the page i unfix the page and go to the
next page in my extent okay this is already more complicated than what we saw before but
this is still oversimplified the real implementation will be more complicated like this why yeah
you have to all kind of problems that you have to handle now for example what about
So if there are more than one transaction in the system,
how do I make sure that I only see tuples
that are visible to me and not tuples
that are updated by another transaction?
So this is probably, there will be here
some transaction logic here in this for loop.
Then you might want to handle deferred updates, for example.
Now, so sometimes you don't want to update immediately
because of write problems.
So you want to delay this,
and then you have to merge this pending update
it comes. Or your table scan might be able to evaluate predicates, which actually is a good
idea usually. So it could be that your table scan is not just outputting all tuples, but you can tell
your table scan, I only want to find tuples where x equals 5. And then the table scan will already
filter. Doing that on this level instead of just a selection on top is a good idea if your physical
representation allows you to skip tuples that are guaranteed not to qualify. And this is often the
So therefore you have a certain incentive to teach your tablet scan
abroad the predicates because this will make your tablet scan faster.
So even a tablet scan tends to be not so super small even though conceptually it's very simple.
Now selection this is really simple there's not much you can do about this.
So we filter all tablets that do not satisfy a predicate P conceptually very simple and
in fact many systems do not even implement it like this.
What you do instead is you piggyback the selection predicate on the previous operator.
So you look at the input of the select and you say, hey, please check this when outputting
tuples.
This sometimes makes sense.
Again, it depends a lot on how your system is implemented.
But combining a selection into whatever is below you is often a good idea.
Not necessarily.
If your tuple passing is really cheap, then you can implement it in a separate operator.
So now if you look at the produce-consume interface, we already looked at this.
Produce of select just calls produce on its input.
Consume of select checks the predicate.
If it's true, we call consume on my consumer.
Otherwise, we just discard the tuple.
Okay.
Now, MAP.
MAP is also a simple operator.
I think it's probably the last of the simple operators.
and what map does, it computes a new column
by evaluating function f.
And again, some systems allow to piggyback a map
on whatever comes below, but this is more rare.
So there are not that many systems that do this,
but you can do this.
And so implementation is if you call the map
to produce values here, we just call produce on my input.
If a type of comes to me,
so somebody calls me with consume,
now I evaluate the function f,
a new column a i attach it to my tupper and then i pass the combined result to my consumer okay so
this is how we compute new columns during query execution okay now so these were all very simple
now we come to an operator that's definitely not simple yeah join is a very complicated operator
and you will most likely have at least two implementations.
Probably you will even have three.
It depends a bit on how good your query optimizers are.
If your query optimizer is really strong, you might get away with only two.
But two is the minimum that you need.
Three is the most likely the minimum that you need.
Okay, why do we need three different implementations of journal?
and three is really the lower bound,
you could easily have four or five.
So you could have more, but three is lower bound.
So why do we need three?
First case here, if you join E1 with E2,
if E2 depends on E1,
then we must use a nested loop join.
So because this is a dependent join
and we must evaluate the right hand side
for every table from the left hand side.
So this calls for a nested loop join
and this is our only choice.
we must use an nested loop join for this.
And this means of course,
that we must implement an nested loop join.
By the way, nested loop joins are absolutely terrible.
You do not ever want to use an nested loop join
if you can avoid it.
Now,
the system I'm currently building
does not have an nested loop join.
Now, how can this be?
Because I just said everybody needs an nested loop join.
Yeah, the escape route is,
if your query optimizer is smart enough
can eliminate the dependent join and so the user has formulated a query where a part of the query
is correlated with other parts of the query so basically you do a select
and then here you do
from r where
some stuff and then we type a sub query here select
blah blah blah from s.
There are some more stuff here where
r.x equals s.y then here group by or something.
So this is a correlated subquery. So we have a subquery where we use inside the subquery,
a part of the outer query here, a correlation.
this forces us to do an nested loop join
and we get terrible runtime.
If your query compiler is smart,
it can rewrite the query for you
so that the inner query is no longer correlated
without the query.
And if you manage to do this,
you don't need an nested loop join.
But of course, to fully eliminate an nested loop join,
you must guarantee that this unnesting always succeeds
so that you are able to remove any kind of
dependency from a query,
and this is quite a bit involved,
but this is possible.
You can build a system that does not need step one,
but I'm only aware of currently two systems
that can do this.
So most database systems will have to implement
a new state loop join for this reason.
Okay, this is one implementation.
Second implementation, if my predicate here,
my joint predicate has a form A equals B,
we can use any joint algorithm.
So this is called an equi-join.
So we join, checking for equality of two values.
Of course, this is the most common case.
And in that case, we can use everything.
And if you can use everything,
most of the time we will use a hash join.
Because hash join is usually the fastest implementation.
So this is what we can use here.
Now, case three, if my sides are not correlated,
but I also do not have an equal condition,
then we can either use an asset loop join,
if you don't want this for performance reasons,
it's terrible,
or we can use a block-wise-tested loop join.
And this gives you the list of join algorithms
probably implement you need a nested loop join probably you want to have a hash join
and you want to have a block-wise nested loop join okay and we will look at the implementation
of these algorithms in a moment i'm just saying so these are the three that you want you might
want to have more like sort merge join or so but this is a minimum that you that you need
okay we start with the first one nested loop join the nested loop join is the most flexible
of the join but also the most simple and the most inefficient yeah so you never want to use a nested
loop join if you can avoid it nested loop join is terrible yeah and now of course very easy to code
but don't do this yeah so basically what we do here is if you coil produce on my nested loop join
it coils produce on its left side if you get a template from the left we store the table on the
left and we ask my right side to produce values if you get a template from the right we concatenate
new tuple with my existing left tuple,
I check the predicate and if it's true,
I call it to my consumer.
So this is like a cross product,
there's an implicit filter condition.
And so what we saw before is cross plus a filter.
So easy, flexible, you can use any predicate piece
that you might have, but you don't want to do this.
Why?
It means easy to see the runtime here is in the order
of size of my left side times size of my right side.
So this is asymptotically N square and N square is usually unacceptable.
Our values of N tend to be super large and a million square is really an unpleasant number.
So therefore try to not to use the nested loop join.
Okay, what else can we do?
So an improvement of the nested loop join is a blockwise nested loop join.
This is a more sane implementation, this is really more efficient.
But it also can be used for any predicates, it's good.
Like the Nessel-Loop-Jones, the blocker Nessel-Loop-Jones can evaluate all predicates that you have.
Like we can check for, I don't know, A is less than B or we can even do more fancy stuff.
A times B plus C cos of this is less than 0.01, something like this.
So if you want, you can evaluate this with block-faceted loop joint and with a nested loop joint.
Any predicate is possible.
And so how does this work algorithmically?
So remember, the nested loop joint loads one tupper on the left,
and for each tupper on the left, it evaluates the right-hand side,
means that we evaluate the right hand side extremely often.
And this is expensive.
Here could be something like this.
So I have a, there's a loop join,
I have here at relation R
and here I have something that's really expensive.
Like it's not, it doesn't have to be a single table.
Could be a group by whatever.
And we evaluate this for every tupper
from the left hand side.
And so this is terribly expensive.
Therefore the block was in the loop join says,
okay, I also have to look at all pairs of values.
but at least I can reduce the number of passes
over the right hand side.
And what you do is you load as many values
from the left into a buffer as you can.
As I have a memory buffer,
you fill this buffer here with values from the left.
Then we evaluate the right hand side
and we compare all my values with my buffer.
And then I have a,
practically it's true, of course I have a match.
And once we are done,
we load a new batch of values into the left hand
this again. Now you at least if you are more theory oriented you could say hey
how is this an improvement because this is also n squared just like the
the nest loop join because after all i combine every table from the left with
every table from the right and that's true but the great advantage is that we
reduce the number of passes over the right hand side by a factor m where m
is my memory size. This can easily be a value of 1000 or 10,000 or 100,000.
Yes, asymptotically it's n-square, but we improve the runtime by a very large constant factor.
So for practical purposes this can be much faster than the nestle loop join.
Of course, even here it's true, if you can avoid it, don't use the blockwise nestle loop join,
use the hash join if you can. There are some predicates you cannot evaluate with the hash join,
and then a block quest and a loop join is what you want to do okay now how does this implementation
work so we need a buffer to store my tupples initially here we clear the buffer we just
throw away everything that we might have now we we call produce on my left side and note that
the real join here happens in the moment we get tupples so therefore we don't see anything
but it could be that after we processed our left side my buffer is not empty actually it's quite
so i might still have tuples in my buffer and if that is the case we do one final pass over
the right hand side to produce all result values now so this is basically the the left over here
that we do in the last if now the interesting work happens in in the consume call so when we
get a tuple from the left so a new tuple comes from the left we check if we still have space
in my buffer so after all i want to write all my tuples in a buffer and if my buffer is full so i
cannot produce i cannot start in the buffer then i call produce on my right hand side so i ask my
right hand side please give me all your tuples so we do this here and afterwards this by the way
this produce quite implicitly joins with the content of my buffer so everything that was in
my buffer has now be joined with my right hand side therefore i can now clear my buffer so i
And now I can store my tupper in the buffer
because now I have a new space.
And when we get the tupper from the right,
so in the second function here,
so when we get a tupper from the right,
we compare it with every tupper in my buffer,
check the predicate, it's true,
we pass it to my consumer, otherwise we throw it away.
Now, so to illustrate the processing,
let's say this is my left relation,
this is my right relation.
So I load as much as I can, for example, this much here in memory.
And first, so this is now in my buffer.
Now I do one pass here over my right hand side and compare everything here with my buffer content.
And if the product is as true as I have a hit.
Okay, afterwards I throw away my buffer content.
So I clear the memory.
I'm not sure if I can draw this.
Yeah, so I clear my memory now because I have already joined it.
I node the next bunch here in memory,
do another pass over my data,
compare it with that bunch,
afterwards I forget my buffer content
and load the rest here.
And this is then the final call,
do one more pass and that's it.
Okay, so in this example here,
we have the right hand side,
the left hand side once and the right hand side three times.
And because my left hand side was three times
memory buffer.
But, so this compared to a nested loop joint,
this dramatically reduces the number of passes
over the right hand side.
So it will be much, much fewer,
depending of course, how much memory you have.
The more memory you have,
the less passes of the right hand side you need.
Okay, now, but nevertheless,
this here is asymptotically in square,
just with better constants than the other one.
Now for an operator that is more efficient, so it has better run times than n squared,
we look at the sort merge join.
So this was historically the first join algorithm that commercial systems implemented as a reasonable
implementation.
So we say we want to take my two inputs e1 and e2 and I want to join them with the sort
merge join and assume now that my predicate has a form e1.a equals e2.b.
that E1 is sorted on A and E2 is sorted on B.
Okay, now there are some,
there's also in the implementation,
also in the naming, what you see here,
there's some confusion is what we consider
a sort merge join.
Strictly speaking, what we're talking about here
is a merge join.
So we don't sort because I assume my input
is already sorted.
In some of the limitations,
it is a true sort merge join in the sense that
it first sorts its input and then does the merge.
But we assume that a sort will be implemented
by different operators.
So we have a separate sort operator that can sort
if we need, and so we can sort them.
And so our sort merge join assumes my input
is already sorted.
Okay, so the good thing about sort merge join is,
so if my input is already sorted,
then I just need a linear pass over both inputs here.
and always skip over the smallest value.
And the moment that it hits two values
that are the same as a joint partner.
Yeah, so skip, joint partner skip,
joint partner skip, and so on.
Yeah, and always skips the smallest one.
Linear pass over the input, no extra memory.
So everything is good.
So this operator is super efficient,
linear runtime, no memory.
But of course this hides the fact,
the expensive part of the third merge joint
This is very, very cheap, but the sort.
The sort of course is an N log N operation.
So sorting is expensive.
Merging is then very cheap.
Okay.
And because here we talk about implementation that does not do the sort.
Therefore it looks like this operator would be super cheap.
And for practical purposes might not be that cheap.
So it's very fast.
And we say here, it's very fast and efficient after sorting.
And so this is of course, there's a downside.
that. Another problem is a sort merge join is super easy in everything as long as you only do
one to n joins. And also which means that one tuple can have n join partners but it cannot happen
that n tuples have m join partners. So this one is okay so I have one value here that joins with
zzzz so that's okay. Also the other direction of course is okay so if I have this here
This is also okay, one value here joins with many here.
But what we do not allow, at least now we have to allow,
we do allow, but let's say,
which makes your life much more difficult is this one here.
So we have a value that joins with Z, Z, Z,
but also the other way around here.
So we have such a scenario.
So this is an N to M join.
So N values from the left join with N values on the right.
Then suddenly this sort merge join is no longer that simple.
is easy n2m is not easy okay and interestingly the sort merge join is about the only operator
that cannot be implemented very nicely in the push model and it can in fact we will show you
the codes how to do this but the push model has some problems with the with the sort merge join
which is while the sort merge join is very easy in the iterator model so iterator model you can
implements this easily. In the push model it's more nasty. So and we dance around this problem by
materializing the left hand side. Now so all my adjoint operators assume that the left hand side
is the smaller side so therefore materializing this side makes sense and if once you have implemented
the left hand side then also the implementation is even in the push model is reasonably easy
but in the iterator model you could implement it without materializing any of the two sides.
I just want to mention this.
Okay, so now with that declaration,
let's look at the code.
So this is an implementation of a third merge join.
So when we are asked to produce values,
so first we prepare some memory here,
because as I said, we materialize the left hand side,
so I prepare some memory or even some temporary segments
where I can write values.
then I scan over my left side so I call left.produce and then I remember so I
have an iterator here so iterator over the left hand side and I set my iterator
to the first spool tuple and then I scan over the right hand side okay now what
do we do if so this one is a trivial case what do you do if we get a tuple
from the left we don't do anything we just spool the value to a temp segment
so we just write it into a temporary relation and then say okay here or one
and then here we say here are all my values.
So real work happens when we get a tupper from the right.
Okay.
So when we get a tupper from the right,
we check is my current iterator.
So remember we have an iterator over the spool values.
Is my current iterator less than the value that's currently coming?
If yes, I advance the iterator.
So I continue processing.
After I've done this, so I make a, so now I have found a value that is not less than
my value, so it's either equal or larger, not less.
Then I remember this position here, so I remember this, I make a copy of my iterator to the
ib value and then as long as the my ib value is equal to my current triplet, so as long
as a joint partner i output ib concordinated with my table and i advance ib plus one okay now you
could ask yourself why why is this so why why do i don't why do i use two different uh operators and
so on yeah so that's the reason of course is duplicates so assume my input here is one two
So then my right hand side is 2, 3, 5, 6, 6, 9.
So we start with setting the iterator here on 1, then my first value 2 comes.
Okay, I see 2 is less than 1, so I advance my iterator.
I go here.
Then I see 2 is equal to 2, so I'll put a joint partner.
Okay, that's easy.
So then the next value comes 3.
2 is less than 3, so I advance 2 here.
I don't have a joint partner, I stop.
Next table comes 5.
4 is less than 5 I advance
to here I have a join partner and now already you see my so my il so this is il so now I start a
new block therefore the ib iterator over the block because I joined with 5 and I also join with the
next value so therefore here in this loop I look at the next value too that's why I join with 5 and
I join with that 5 and then I'm done.
Now comes the 6.
See, 5 is less than 6, so therefore I advance my pointer to the next 5.
This 5 is still less than 6, so I advance the pointer to the next 5.
Sorry, not the next 5, the next value is then they get a 6.
We find a joint partner.
We also look at the next value, we find a joint partner.
But note that we do not advance the IL-Zeiger, sorry, mixing German and English.
IL pointer. So we're still pointing to the first six not to the second six. Why? When the next six
comes, which happens here, so then we must still find the first six as joint partner. So therefore
now if you say here this here is a joint partner and then we advance and then we say that here is
a joint partner. Okay so this is the N2M case, two values from left one with joint with two values
from the right.
Okay, so, but this is how it works.
Now I said the n2m case is difficult and this code here is not that difficult because we
have cheated, namely we have already materialized the left hand side.
And therefore we can just read it multiple times as long as we want.
So this is no problem.
Now there are some pretty tricky and advanced implementations that do the n2m case correctly
without making a copy of the left hand side.
Now this is more involved to process.
And also it does not work well
with the consume-produce model.
It works with the iterator model
but not with the produce-consume model.
Now, if you do want to do this fancy handling
without materialization,
this is what we see here as a marked as beta.
What you do is we scan both lists in parallel,
which we can do in the iterator model.
We can ask each side, give me values.
both sides and parallel and as long as they are different we just skip over the values
only in the moment that we have found a match we start making copies
so then we make a copy until the current block of value ends
so like for this example here we said one two three four five five six six
so we scan here we make no copy then we make a copy of the fives because we don't know how many
on the right hand side we will see.
So we copy the values of five.
Now, when we are done with five,
we forget these five.
And now we're just making copies of six.
Now we only copy what we need to the end-to-end case.
Okay, but this is not so super easy to implement.
Now this is quite, quite involved to do this.
Here we get, because we always materialize
the left hand side, our code is quite simple.
By the way, I said historically,
sort merge join was the first good joint implementation so the first efficient joint
implementation i think today it's largely irrelevant very few people will want to use a
sort merge join why yeah because sort merge can it be parallelized very well it depends of how
of course how your data is stored but in general so merchants usually suitable for single threaded
execution but not for multi-threaded execution and if you have a machine with
64 cores then single-threaded simply does not matter. Single-threaded is an
irrelevant case if you have a high number of cores. Everything has to be
done in parallel and SWOT MERGE JOIN is not very suited for parallel execution.
Therefore what you want to do is this one here, hash join.
Okay so again like a SWOT MERGE JOIN we assume that my
equals b and what we do here is we build a hash table for the left side and then we probe the
hash value for the value from the right side now of course there are different cases and complexity
and in memory case in an external memory case the in memory case is quite simple the external
memory case is not so simple and of course in in reality you will probably want to have a hybrid
implementation because you don't know reliable how large your input is yeah so you will first
try to do everything in memory and when you run out of memory you fall back to the external memory
so you switch to this um to the slower algorithm if you have to okay but because we don't know this
in beforehand this makes the code quite complicated here we split them in separate code paths we say
we have one in memory hash join and we have an external memory has joined and we describe them
easier to talk about this okay so let's start with looking at the in-memory hash join
so when we call produce of the in-memory hash join we prepare a hash table where all my
values from the left side will be stored in then i scan my left side putting everything that was
in the left side in the hash table then i scan my right hand side and check the hash table for
joint partners yeah and if we have luck with statistics which of course we hope that we have
then this algorithm has linear runtime uh no i shouldn't say linear runtime uh more is very
very dangerous to to say this it has linear runtime if you only have key from key joints
yeah so um but in general because it could be that we have growing joints so that my output is
is larger than my input.
And if that happens, therefore the runtime
of this algorithm here is expected.
So if we look at the runtime of L join R,
so we expect that the runtime here is in order of size
of L plus size of R, which is linear,
plus unfortunately size of L join R.
Now, so this is what we want to have.
Now, why is this term?
Because you must produce your output and of course you cannot be faster than your output.
And if your output is super linear, so output is larger than your input, then of course
your algorithm cannot be better than this.
So then we are also super linear.
But this is usually not the case.
Most queries don't do this.
Therefore we expect here to have linear runtime in my hash join.
Which of course is very good.
Now how can we implement this?
So we already saw the produce side, now about the consume side.
Then we get the tuple from the left, we just take this tuple and store it in the hash table.
So we see this is my join key, I just say hey for the value 5 I have that tuple, for
the value 10 I have that tuple.
So we have a hash table that tells me for each join key what is the corresponding tuple
or corresponding tuple of course can be a multiple.
Now, when we get a tuple from the right,
now we've searched these joint partners.
So here now I look, I look, take a look my tuple,
I look into my hash table and check here, okay,
which tuples do we have that belong to this hash key?
Now, after we found them, we still check the predicate.
Why?
If you remember back about hash tables,
so this look up here will only find entries
that have the same hash value, yeah?
And could be that we have hash collisions,
not very likely, but could be that we have two values
that are relatively different,
but by chance gets the same hash value.
Now here we have to check if this is the case.
So we check the predicate just to be sure.
And now if the predicate is true,
then we really have a joint partner, okay?
And so, yeah, so the implementation
of in-memory hash joint is actually quite simple.
If you want to be more flexible, of course here at some point we would have to check if we are full
If you run out of memory here, I actually check it before of course and before storing in a cache there is check space
And if you run out of space we cannot store the tupples then we fall back to the external memory case
And otherwise you try to be in memory. Okay, so this is how we would implement the hybrid implementation
In-memory has joined still quite simple.
Now, if we do not fit into your memory,
then suddenly we become much, much, much more complicated.
As you see already that we need multiple slides here,
just because there are so many things that we have to do
and that can go wrong.
Okay, so let's look at this piece by piece.
So how can we implement the external memory has joined?
So we start by preparing an in-memory spool buffer because we don't always want to write to disk
so we keep as much in-memory as we can
Then we also prepare some space on disk, some temporary segments that we can use for spooling
So we then we rewrite everything down
Okay, then we define initial partition boundaries. Now what does this mean?
So first perhaps before looking at the code I should explain the algorithm
I mean I hope actually that you have already looked at this in your introduction to databases
yeah because this here is the so-called grace hash join. So grace hash join and what does this
join do? So if this is my left side and this is the domain of my left side
so let's say this is the value a and this here is the value b
and this is of course the smallest possible value and then this is the largest possible value
either by looking at the real values or in our case most likely we just look at the hash values
after all we are hash join yeah we compute the hash value of my of my join attributes then I
have a smallest possible hash value probably zero and have a largest possible value probably
two to the power of 63 minus one okay and uh now if the the smaller side would fit in memory then
everything would be easy because it was just stored in hash tables that it would be done
but if the my side is the left side here is too large what i can do it i'd cut my my side here
into parts like this four parts in this case such that each part can fit in memory of course the
number of cuts that I do, the number of partitions depends on how large my relation is.
The larger my relation is, the more cuts do I need.
So I want to cut it such that my each partition fits in memory.
And then after deciding the partitions, I partitions the other side too by the same
criterion.
For example, I mean, let's just to make up some numbers.
Of course, this is totally bogus here, but I want to get so nice small numbers.
So this says this is zero and this is 16 exclusively.
And I could for example say everything up to 4 exclusive goes in the first partition,
everything between 4 and 8 goes to second, between 8 and 12 goes here and between 12
and 16 goes to the last one.
And then I would do the same partitioning on the other side even though you don't have
to fit it in memory but nevertheless you do it.
And then so also here 0, 4, 8, 12, 16.
and now you know that joint partners can only occur on this diagonal
nobody else can join why everyone we know that these values must be equal in the end
because my predicate is a equals b therefore i know i can only find a joint partner but if my
the hash value is between 0 and 4,
the hash value of the other guy must also be between 0 and 4.
Yeah, so therefore I only have to look at this diagonal here.
And this is the idea of grace hash join.
Now, so if you partition both sides,
and then we look at the corresponding partition.
So basically this partition looks at that,
this here looks at that, this here looks at that,
and this here looks at that,
and we ignore everybody else.
And so we only look at the corresponding partition,
and this allows me to find my joint partners.
and now there are some unpleasant things that can happen namely we might have to
recursively repartition we hope this is never happens yeah but hope is not truth
because so how can this happen that we might have to repartition we want to
partition my input such that each partition and each partition from the
left at least so from the build side that each partition from the left fits in
memory this is what we want and and as in my example I said and for this I break
and put it into four partitions.
But how do I know that I should use four?
Why four? Why not eight?
You know, or some other value.
Basically what we do is we want to use estimates.
We look at how large is my memory,
how large is the tuple, how many tuples do I have?
And then I estimate, okay,
I believe we need four partitions.
And most, in most cases it's probably true.
Sometimes we are probably, we'll be wrong
because tuple size are very uneven
or we simply did not know precisely
we would get because it could be a predicate of the user predicate on input so i don't know how
large my input will be and then i guess wrong and if this happens then i might have to repartition
recursively to to until the each partition fits in memory now so this is a rare case but this can
happen okay and once i manage to break it into small enough pieces that everything fits then
the problem is easy again because then we basically come back to the in-memory case that we already saw
So this is the high level algorithm.
Here is now the corresponding code.
I said already we prepare a spooling buffer in memory
and we prepare a spooling buffer on disk.
Then we define initial page boundaries.
This is of course, it basically means we guess.
Not only guessing, we look at statistics that we have,
but we try to find a good partition boundary, let's say.
okay and then we call produce on my left side and this partitions the left side into the chosen
partitions now then we flush the in-memory buffer if we have to because this could be or actually
it's quite likely that we still have tuples in my buffer when we have finished then we repartition
the left hand side if we have to so this now checks if we if partitions were fine or if you
should have chosen finer partitions so this repartitions if needed afterwards i read the
and produce it into partitions.
Here we never have to repartition again
because we only want to partition
such that the left hand side fits in memory.
If the right hand side is larger than memory, that's okay.
Okay, again, then we flush buffers
if we have tuppets in my buffers
and finally we produce all joint partners.
As you can already see,
this is clearly a full pipeline breaker
because we have processed both left and right side
before producing any output values.
Okay, so a good classic a great search joint breaks a pipeline on both sides
But in memory case breaks it only on the right. Okay, now let's look at the individual pieces here
First what do we do if we get a tupper from the left?
first phase
So we get a tupper from the left and what we want to do is you just want to put it into my in-memory
Pool have a rough of a memory. We just put it in there
and if you can do this it's just fine we do it and if my buffer is full so this is what this if
checks if my buffer is full if yes so my buffer can no longer store a new tupple then I must write
my tupples to disk and so this is an external memory has joined so we can we write everything
to disk that doesn't fit so before we do this we we sort my values in the buffer by hash value
and then we write the entries to the corresponding partitions okay and now
you could ask yourself why sorting now so we do sort because this means that
tuples that belong to the same partition will be next to each other in memory
and this is good because this gives me a nice consecutive IO pattern so you can
just write everything one one partition out sequentially then the next
partition out sequentially next out sequentially so we get sequential IO on
disk and remember when we said in the past sequential I.O. is extremely important
for disks so we want this for performance reasons even for SSDs by the
way it is not only for rotating disks you want to have right locality now so
we therefore sorting memory pays off okay then we update the partition
statistics basically we remember how many tuples do we have and how large was
each tuple so how much space did we use then we empties the buffer and then we
we now have space for the next tuple.
Okay, then after this we can install the tuple.
And we do this till the end.
Okay, so after we process the left hand side,
everything was written out into partitions.
Now we must check if this is fine.
It could be that if we're lucky,
we don't have to do anything.
Or if my partition is too large.
It could be that my partition is larger than my memory.
So this is what we check here
in this function repartition left.
So basically what we do here is we loop over all partitions and we check if the partition is larger than memory.
If yes, a lot of special cases, we check if the number of hash values that we have is larger than one.
Basically what we remember is what is the largest and the smallest hash value that we have in my partition.
If they are equal, I have only one value, then I have a problem.
And then if this happens, then we mark the partition here as overflow.
we say oh this is a large partition with only one value you have to treat this especially okay i
hope this never happens and if we have more than one hash value then we can find a newer
partition boundary so i solve c for example f hash values between 10 and let's say 30 and i know
that my partition is two largest three times larger than memory then i will choose new boundaries yes
here and here such that everything is now evenly distributed okay and so we
do this line we derive new new partition boundaries we load the partition in
memory and then we write out each partition with each part out into this
final partition boundary so we transform one big partition basically into
into three partitions.
Now, so first, second, and third.
And of course, we hope that now
these three partitions do fit.
Now, if we would be extremely unlucky,
of course, this could see be too large,
then we would repeat this until it fits.
But hopefully this never happens.
Okay, and so basically we bring the external memory case
down to the in-memory case,
because once the partition does fit in memory,
everything else is quite simple.
Now coming back to this overflow case here,
this is a special case and this can happen for example,
if you have a lot of duplicates in that relation,
like it could be that my relation contains
1 million times the same value.
And if the value is really the same,
yeah, I cannot do anything.
If the values are the same,
they will of course have the same hash value.
So a new, no partitioning strategy
will ever solve this problem for me.
So if you have real duplicates or hash collisions,
hash collisions could also be, but this is unlikely.
If you have functions, good hash collision,
not very likely, but you could have real collisions,
as real duplicates, and then we can have a partition
that is larger than memory, and we cannot make it smaller.
Okay, and if this happens,
then we just remember it and treat it specially.
Now, if you get a tupper from the right,
this is now, looks,
It's a principle just like the get tupper from the left case.
So the only difference is now we are sure
that my partition boundary is correct.
Because the right hand side no longer has to guess
partition boundaries.
Then we scan the left hand side,
we have already, after we scan the left hand side,
we already picked my boundary.
So at this point we do know.
Okay.
Otherwise the code is the same.
The tupper comes, we check if there's space.
If yes, we just put it in the buffer.
If no, we sort my values by hash value.
We spool out my, write out my values
in the corresponding partitions,
we empty the buffer and we continue.
Okay.
And now there is a remaining interesting part,
of course, is the join.
So because after this, after this here,
we have partitioned both my left and my right hand side.
And we know that my left partitions do fit in memory.
The right hand side, not necessarily, they can be larger,
but the left side will be fit in memory.
The final step here is join partitions and this now produces the real output values.
For this we look at all partitions.
There are two cases here, the good and the bad case.
We check if P is an overflow partition, that is the bad case.
If yes, we call the function join partition overflow, special logic here.
Otherwise the regular case we just call a join partition.
And again this is a great size join idea because we have an equal join, we know that we can
partners within the partition so on the diagonal in this domain space and
therefore it's sufficient to look at the same partition in each in each side
and yeah the overflow case needs some special care so first look at the regular
case the joint partition case we get a partition P so then what we do is we
load P so this part of my domain space into memory in a hash table and we know
possible because we checked yeah so we we in this recursive repartitioning make sure
that each partition on the left fits so this here must succeed okay so we load it in the
hash table if it's possible and now this remaining code here this looks basically like the in-memory
hash join so so what we do is we loop over all tuples in the corresponding partition
on the right and so here then we check the hash table for a joint partner here we check
if this is a truly equal or not a hash collision here and if it's truly equally output result
now so this basically at this point here we have reached the in-memory case because we know that
my left hand side must fit as the right hand side can be utterly large i mean this of course makes
you are this for each t and repetition a bit more more difficult but not really difficult you know
because also here we mean if it's very large we just load a page with tuples and after we have
so we loop over all pages that contain values but this is not so super complicated
okay and now the the special case is that we did have to process this now is um i said the other
case was like um in memory has joined this here is log like a blockbuster loop join because we know
that my partition doesn't fit because i have so many identical values so all values are equal
if my vacuoles are equal then what should I do?
And so I have to look all of them in sequence.
So here we look at, we load from by,
so you look at the partition P,
we load from P as much as we can in memory,
which might not be everything
because it could be too large,
but we load as much as we can in memory.
We put it in a hash table
and then runs the in-memory hash join here.
And after we're done, we load the next chunk.
and I see we basically do this repeatedly.
This is like a cross here between a block list
and a loop join.
So we read the right hand side repeatedly,
add a hash join.
So we still use hash table to find to speed up matches.
But the principle we have to process the right hand side
as often as we need to get the data into my system.
left hand side divided by memory size.
This is the number of passes that we need.
Okay, so these are the bread and butter join algorithms,
basically, so this is that we saw nested loop join,
block-wise nested loop join, sort merge join, hash join.
And so this is so the most common,
so most systems will implement at least,
perhaps even all of them, or at least many of them.
And so these are the most common ones.
There's some other stuff here that you can do for example you might potentially optimize
for the case that you know for sure that the left hand side contains only a single tuple
yeah and why would you want to do this yeah because this is not that uncommon.
For example if you bind the primary key you know that there will be only one tuple at
most or none could of course the value doesn't exist but if you have something here let's
where key equals seven then you know for sure that this gives you one double at most or none
okay and um or other cases are like you do a group by and then you know they can be only one value
or you do a scalar subcaries this can also produce only one value this is quite common that this
happens okay and um if you can guarantee that you will have at most one value then the joint
implementation is particularly simple okay now you could say uh you can use this loop join yeah
and it's true of course you can use in this loop join and but uh the in fact the singleton join is
even simpler yeah and therefore you because it's so easy to build you might want to use this
yeah so to produce we just call a produce on my left hand side and when we get a table from the
left we just copy it and remember that this happens at most once as there could
be zero or one tuple from the left but never more now so therefore we just
store the tuple from the left and the variable and that's it and then when we
get the tuple from the right and now this of course can be many this happens
here I concretely add the new tuple with my copied value and check the predicate
and if it's true I output it to the consumer now so this is basically an
optimized version to make this simple joint even simpler and so this is now super cheap
okay and another kind of problem that we have to implement is non-inner joints yeah so far we said
all joints that consider the inner joints we said here i want to find tuples where the values are
the same but these are not the only ones yeah so first we have of course the outer joints like here
full outer. So for these joints you must even produce a tuple if it does not have a joint
partner. So remember introduction to the databases, an outer join is like an inner join but a
tuple that did not find a joint partner is padded with null values and then output it
regardless. So we have to produce non-matching tuples too. And then we have also the semi-joins.
So here we have to output only matching tuples without multiplicities.
So this means if you have one joint partner, we must produce a value.
If you have 10 joint partners, we must also produce a value, but only once.
So let's say if I do here, this one here, 1, 2, 3, 4, and on my right hand side here,
I have 2, 4, 4, 4, 5, and then I do a semi-joint between them.
must be one doesn't have a joint partner,
two has a joint partner, yes, so it must be two,
three doesn't have a joint partner,
four does have a joint partner,
in fact it has multiple joint partners,
but we don't care, we should only output four once.
Okay, so for these four similar joints,
that's a problem, we output only once,
and then for anti-joints, we only output
tablets that do not have a joint partner,
again, with all multiplicities, only once.
okay and now at a high level we can in fact implement all these just like a regular joint
so we want to have your regular joint implementations you can handle all these too but you will need
some additional bookkeeping particularly you have to remember if somebody has a joint partner or not
now so the idea is that for non-inner joints you mark a tuple that has a remembering if it has a
okay and so when we do this here my input was say one two three my output
here was other side is two four six I do a regular join here I find a join
partner and then I remember okay two had a join partner these two had join
partners so I remember that these have join partners okay and now when we do an
outer join we first do the regular inner join and then we do an additional pass
and we check if my table was marked and if yes it has a joint partner if not we output the
table padded with null values okay for example if we would do
if we will do this one here so a left outer join yeah then we if we do not
as in this particular case here we would output two two of course this was my first match then we
null and three null. And we figure this out by checking the marks afterwards. So we check the
left hand side and we check. We do not have to check the right hand side because we don't care.
And in fact, from this joint we would not even mark the right hand side. I have not
did markers on both sides. Of course the system would be smart and realize the right hand side
does not have to be marked. So in this case we would only mark the right hand side, sorry,
the left hand side. But in this case, for example, you would have to mark both sides.
both sides depending what you have okay so the auto joints mark and this
additional output be outputs values if if they are marked the semi joints they
also mark but they only output the value if it is not marked yet
yeah so basically if i have a if i find a match i check did this tupper already
find another match if yes don't do anything if if no mark it and do output
it okay if you want to do this multi-thread it this requires you to use atomics basically you
have to do this check and mark in one atomic operation and so you must say okay please mark
this and if i'm the first to mark it then i will output so anti-join process is like the auto join
more or less so we we we run the regular drive we mark but we do not output output so we just mark
we throw away the matches afterwards we just mark them and then we do an additional pass over the
non-marked tuples because these were the ones that did not have a joint partner
this is what we want to have okay so this works nice the only problem is okay
where do we store the marker bit now so somehow we must get a bit from somewhere
that allows me to to say okay this had a joint partner or yes or no and now
marking the left side is usually easy so the left side is the one that sits in a
hash table somewhere now so this is not a not a big deal because what we can do
is we just change just reserve a single bit or single byte whatever that we
serve you make this type of tiny bit smaller sorry larger and smaller it's
tiny bit larger then we reserve one bit or one byte and then when we have a
joint partner we write in this byte yes i had a joint partner and then we can
check this afterwards okay so this is this is easy marking the right hand side
This is not so easy, it depends on what kind of operator you are.
If you read the right hand side only once, like in hash join, hash join reads the right
hand side only once.
If you do a single pass over the right hand side then it's okay because then we just have
a local variable somewhere or register which works as a marker and then when we have a
joint partner which sets this variable to true and afterwards you check did we have
a joint partner.
Okay, that's okay.
but if we do something like this okay who is so insane to do this but yeah you
know you can potentially then suddenly you have a problem because now we read
the right hand side multiple times yeah and we must remember of course if in the
previous pass over my right hand side this table was marked or not so now this
This is more difficult because there is no obvious place where I can put the marker on
my right hand side.
So what you probably want to do in this case, you want to maintain an extra data structure,
so some associative data structure that says okay tuple 5 was marked, tuple 10 was marked,
tuple 20 was marked.
So you remember basically which tuple's did find a drawing partner.
Now one observation here is that in most queries, not always of course, but in most queries
you tend to have locality, which means either nothing is joined or everything is joined for a particular range of tupples.
It's extremely common that you have a range of tupples that all have a joint partner.
Then perhaps you might have another range that have non-joint partners.
Therefore, this associated data structure, you probably want to use interval compression.
So you don't want to just want to have, means the most trivial implementation, of course, would be to say,
I just store a set of tabl IDs or something yes this would be possible yeah but this would
probably waste a lot of space instead what you want to have is some fancy data structure
that stores okay tuples 10 to 50 all joined tuple 90 to 105 all joined and so on and so
So you want to store the runs of values, intervals of values.
And then you no longer have a problem.
I mean, think about the extreme case.
Everybody finds a joint partner.
Now it can easily happen.
And then you want this extra data structure
that you have is very small.
And so you don't want to make it as large as the relation.
Now, so if you use interval compression,
it's not a problem because we just say,
hey, from first tupper to last tupper,
everybody has a joint partner.
Now implementing such a thing is not so super easy,
But you can do this for example using a B-tree where the intervals are stored in a B-tree
and if an interval grows and touches the neighboring interval it's merged with its neighbor.
So then the number of intervals that you have is kept reasonably low.
Okay and just me quickly check my time.
Oh I'm seeing I'm running out of time already.
So we look today at different ways to implement joints.
Of course, knee joints are super important operators,
but they're not the only ones.
There are also some others that we have to process
like a sort and group by,
but this we will do in the next lecture.
Okay, thank you.